so I am Barbara I'm a software developer
at our studio I am in the shiny team and
I'm going to talk today a little bit
about shiny but mostly about databases
how do you interact with databases from
are in general and then specifically in
shiny because that brings a whole new
set of concerns so to give you an idea
of what I have planned for this talk I
kind of see it as having two parts parts
one is mostly what we're going to spend
the sime on and it's going to basically
be about databases database best
practices in our in particular I'm going
to go through a set of packages that
really help you when you're interacting
me data business in R and I'm going to
show how they build on top of each other
so very quickly vbi is a package that
helps you standardize your interactions
with the database from our ODBC is a
really powerful DBI backend which will
make sense when I get to it and the
prior is a pack it's probably the
practice of most of you now here that's
the package that is really great for
wrangling and transforming data in a
tidy way any can be used for database
for database as well so not only memory
data but also remote data and lastly the
pool package is actually the only
package that I wrote from those what I'm
going to talk about today and that's the
one that relates most to shiny
so pool helps you to connect to a
database from shiny using all of these
other packages so that's my main goal
for today but part two of the talk is
I'm going to try to spend a few minutes
on a shiny app demo that I've created
for this talk it's a crud app so it
means that you can create read update
and delete data from a database all from
within a shiny apps all from within our
in this case I chose a sequel Lite
database which is local and really fast
and doesn't require internet so part two
is going to take a lot less time than
part one because I hope that you will be
motivated to look at the app if
if that's interesting to you and I just
really want to demo it quickly all right
so databases at the risk of
oversimplifying you can think of
databases as being in one of two
categories there's relational databases
and then there's the newer no sequel or
object-oriented databases we'll focus on
the first one and that's mostly for
historical reasons they've been around
for longer the infrastructure around
them in general not just an AR is
stronger and very quickly relational
databases and their management systems
store data in columns and rows these
make up tables
it looks spreadsheet II and they use SQL
which is a language for querying data a
few popular databases that are
relational or in this case open source
are my sequel Postgres and sequel Lite
recently for distributed systems you
also have things like Apache hive and
fodder Impala which are relational like
and most of these packages work really
well with relational databases there's
nothing stopping them from working with
the no sequel databases there needs to
be more infrastructure there and that we
haven't gone into it yet so I'm going to
skip over this a little bit and get
right into the packages so the first
foundational package that we're
interested in when it comes to databases
in our it's called vbi and it stands for
database interface and the whole idea of
vbi is that it's a standard it's an
interface that defines how you should
interact with the database from our so
basically it as s3 generics which are
functions that then are implemented for
particular types of connections so dbi
itself doesn't care what type of
connection you have it just says that it
whatever it is your connection you have
to implement this method for connecting
that method for disconnecting
and a bunch of other methods so the
advantage of this is that you get
different databases using basically the
same language and that gives you a lot
of portability in your code you can
basically migrate your database to
another system and be able to use a lot
of your old code so one thing that I
want to note particularly is that as I
said DVI itself doesn't care what is the
particular database you're using all of
that work is done by other packages and
these packages will implement all of
these methods for a particular database
or a database management system so these
are the so-called vbi compliance
backends our sequel Lite or my sequel
our Postgres are all examples of vbi
compliance packages and so you need to
use both of them if you want to connect
to I can see qualité database and so and
if this sounds like extra work to you
again the advantage is that by having
vbi you have a very portable language
for a lot of different packages in
practice a vbi looks like this you can
create a connection by calling VV
connect in this case I am creating a
connection to a sequel Lite database in
memory you can write a table you can get
a query this is SQL right here so it you
have to be a little bit fluent in SQL
and when you're done is you need to
disconnect your connection which is very
important because if you forget to do
this and you're doing a lot of queries
and creating a lot of connections you
will actually leak a lot of connections
so the gist of it's pretty simple one
thing that I want to note in DVI before
we move on is that it also provides
really good sequel injection prevention
function so a sequel injection is when
users third parties can go to your app
or go to your program and inject code
that has basically malicious intents so
in this case even though the string here
is asking for a name a user can do this
and and if you're not escaping this
correctly this can cause your database
to lose a whole table so this has been a
problem ever since relational databases
have existed and the whole point of here
the punchline as this comic is that you
need to sanitize your database inputs
and vbi has a lot of functions for that
so keep that in mind that is important
so moving on to ODBC I'm going to spend
very little time on this ODBC a is yet
another standard yet another
specification so ODBC unlike DVI however
is independent of operating system
programming language and it really is
just a standard API of how to interact
with databases how this relates to our
is that very recently we have the ODBC
package ODBC now in lower case which is
a DB I compliance back-end so what this
means is that if you have an ODBC driver
for a package that has been written by
whomever that is not an R because ODBC
is not language dependent and then you
have the VI in ODBC you don't need to
write your own driver for whatever
database you want to connect to if you
already have the ODBC driver so that's
the real power of this any really
augments the power of DB I by sending it
to so many other databases that didn't
have specific drivers in practice it
looks very similar to what we've seen
already you have DB connect you have a
series of arguments one thing to note is
that since you're always connecting with
ODBC these arguments are actually the
same always now that it's always UID for
example instead of user
or username or one of the thousand
variants that you can have and then you
can continue doing doing a very similar
job disconnecting at the end the plier
so the idea now that you know about DVI
and you can use DVI for so many things
the idea to take it one level up is to
not have to worry about sequel and just
use the plier syntax use our code to
talk to a database to extract data to
insert data to transform data so the
plier extends and wraps a lot of DVI
methods and you can do most of what you
can do what you can do with the VI in
sequel directly we'd apply NR there are
a few things that you feel me dbi for
because the plier is not magic although
it seems like it's sometimes and there
have been actually a very recent revamp
of the plier and the introduction of a
new package called DB plier so this is a
fresh off the presses and the bottom
line I think is if you have if you're
used to R and if you're used to the deep
layer verbs like filter and mutation and
group by and summarize it's a very good
idea to go with apply it also does a
bunch of optimizations for you with
sequel translation and lazy evaluation
so you never loading data into our until
you need it so if the player is good
enough for you it tends to be a great
idea to use it and I hope this slide
makes it really clear weighted so as you
can see we have exactly the same
standard for connection that we have
with EBI but now to query it we are just
using the apply year we're piping things
it's very easy for us to read as human
beings we have a connection you asked
for the table called city and any ask
for the first two rows and that's it
it's very intuitive there's no select
asterisk from city limit to that we had
to deal with before
so finally pool so after all these
packages why do we need another one and
the problem that pool tries to solve is
how what is the best way to interact
with the database from shiny so shiny
brings its own set of constraints
therefore every one session there's only
a single our process and potentially
many users establishing connections to a
remote database can take quite a while
and they can go down at any time because
of network problems or a bunch of other
things so you're really in this
conundrum that you don't want a fresh
connection for every query that you make
for every user action because I would be
so slow but you also don't want one
connection for app because what if it
breaks down what if there's two users
trying to make a query at the same time
so the pool package is meant to solve
this problem by creating a pool of
connections and it's so expressive the
connections from the remote server and
then it keeps them locally and you can
check them out as you need and return
them and it does this kind of behind the
curtain so you don't even notice it's
actually very similar to how DB I look
except for the creating and the closing
of the pool itself so the idea is that
it's kind of like having one connection
for query except that the connections
now are local and are recycled so every
time you're done with a connection it
goes back to the pool and can be used
again so it gives you a usually very
good performance and it takes care of
connection management so it is mainly
pool is mainly important for shiny apps
because of this whole interactive
context I was talking about but you can
be used in any other context without any
problem you might not me that
necessarily but it definitely doesn't
hurt and it also integrates seamlessly
with both EBI and v player will be on
cran really soon and to have an idea of
what it looks like as you can see we
still have our connection our
disconnection our query the query is
exactly the same as it is we'd apply or
DB I and the only thing really that
change is
instead of calling DB connect I'm
calling DB pool and instead of calling
DB disconnect I'm calling pool clothes
and this takes care of making all the
connections and all those connections
that you might need I have some
resources here I'm not going to go
through them now because time is short
but um the link is available at the desk
or however they're distributing it and
you can check them out later so very
quickly
um the shiny app that I built that is a
credit this is kind of what it looks
like you can see there's a few well
maybe you cannot see but there's a few
options you can create a table you can
actually going to just show it I think
you're going to see it better
all right so sorry for the zoom the idea
here is that there's an overview page it
shows you the tables you already have in
this case I already populated this table
with one at this database with one table
and you can see here okay so you can see
here that it's a very small table I've
got three rows three columns and it's
kind of an inventory for those of you
who can read at the back there's ID and
then an item and how many of those you
have it's kind of an inventory type
thing so you can create a new entry so
for and once you create entry you can
see it's immediately reflected here
there's now four rows if you read you'll
see there's now a new row you can update
an entry so in this case if I want to
update the one I've just done because
I've got some more watches in this case
I can do that and again it's
automatically reflected here I can also
delete rows and do all of the sender
things that you'd like to do with a
credible possible using shiny vbi the
plier and puh all the source codes
available with the repo where these
slides live as well and I encourage you
to look at it if you're curious
it covers basically it puts into
practice basically everything I talked
about in here thank
[Applause]
yeah
couple of weeks yeah it's I so what the
player was just released a couple of
weeks ago and it changed a lot of things
so I was waiting for that to update pool
and get it really sequin without having
to break compatibility which would have
happen so now that's done and I've
actually finished it for use are what I
wanted to do it'll be like one more week
for me to test things completely and
then I'll submit it to Ken